[Music]
President Trump is expected to meet with
members of law enforcement later today
now this comes after protesters flooded
the streets again over the weekend
demanding an end to police brutality and
the defunding of police forces I spoke
with the heads of four police
departments ATS Dallas Police Chief
Renee Hall Santa Cruz police chief
Andrew Mills Camden New Jersey Police
Chief Joseph Wysocki and last but
certainly not least Raleigh Police Chief
Casandra dick Brown so we discussed many
things including the flaws in the system
and the need for change but we started
with the reaction to the video of George
Floyd's death I was angry at the
profession because it took me back to
why police saying even exist in the
first place
police officers exist because of slave
patrols so there's something that goes
back to that one of the things that was
so disturbing is that it seems so
Cavalier and so cruel on some level he
must have felt comfortable doing what he
did because in the past there doesn't
appear to have been consequences for
their actions okay all I think you're
right I think it's a fairly small
percentage but it's a significant
percentage of people who feel empowered
and the mere fact that the other
officers didn't intercede it is they're
just as guilty if you see it you own it
I agree it's the one one thing I think
we have to stress the duty to intervene
we need to stress stress that do you
think most police officers feel
comfortable reporting bad behavior from
another officer yeah you know I think it
is tough to turn out the cops in because
you depend on them for your life and
they make sometimes make poor decisions
and you're going to try to do what you
can to protect them but we've got to get
past that generally speaking what could
I have a show of hands do you think that
black people are treated differently
than white people by the police in this
country
that was a unanimous that was a
unanimous I think there are differences
and they are systemic it's community
based as well it's not just in law
enforcement and how many of us have been
in a store and people have walked around
while you're shopping being because of
the color of your skin and I think now
is that time to really pay attention to
where we are and to really be a part of
the change here's the reality for me I'm
a 63 year old white guy from a new class
family with an education I'm privileged
nobody's gonna kneel on my neck I would
guess 4 percent of our police agencies
shouldn't be there but those are the 4
percent that we've got to get rid of you
have to figure out how to do that
that is where the racism occurs I think
we need to take a look at how unions are
empowered to protect the officers
immediately the police union there said
don't condemn the officer and don't rush
to judgment and I think that's another
thing that bothers people that even when
we see something that appears to be so
blatant it's still wait a second don't
rush to judgment let there be an
investigation you know some of the
issues that have come up have been that
same issue is that police association
coddled officers and they make their
behavior acceptable do you think that's
true do you think that's true absolutely
I do I think in in some instances there
are Association members who regardless
of the behavior of an officer we blame
everything else this is not the first
case where an unarmed black man was
killed where people think unfairly
unjustified this feels different to me
does it to you yeah Gail it does feel
different to me it shocked the
consciousness of the profession is
shallow symbolism of just a one time
speaking out we can't stop here and I
mean where were we when some of these
other people were killed there was a lot
of silence from our profession and for
that we are wrong I am wrong I am sorry
why do you think Chiefs didn't speak up
before it had to be something this
heinous chief all the
positions or in if we're going to be
truthful about it our very political and
so I think the balance of what is true
and right versus what is politically
correct to say gets in the way but I
believe that we're sick and tired of
being sick and tired as a nation because
we see that their systemic change that
has to take place in order for us to be
on the other side of this and I think
what we're seeing now as a result of the
pain of the hurt of the tired is a
result of not having that seat at the
table but weren't you all aware of the
pain the hurt and the tired to use your
words chief Hall before the murder of
George Floyd we've seen it in all of our
nothing change and nothing changed so
when we say nothing's changed I don't
think we're being you know genuine in
that the fact that things have changed
but he may not have done a good enough
job of informing them that these
recommendations have come in and we
implemented them I want to talk to you
all about the protest chief Wysocki
President Obama singled your department
out for the way that you handle
protesters so what are you doing that
the rest of the country could learn from
we weren't in riot gear we weren't and
you have a helmet on or like the big big
sticks we just read on regular uniform
you know we marched and you have to
continually be doing community policing
you have to do community outreach and
you have to listen chief Rosa you made
national news for kneeling with the
protesters and their demonstrators we
stand for justice and we stand for
making sure that racial and justices are
dealt with and so it's not just the
black community speaking out you have a
lot of community speaking out but now we
have to follow through with real policy
changes legislative changes training and
I hope if there's leadership in
Washington to ensure that this takes
place in a thoughtful way and in a rapid
way that was Andy Mills listen all of
them were very good talkers I found Andy
Mills to be
especially forthcoming in his thoughts
they all agree that leadership that
change starts at the top and leadership
is key and there they have to be the
ones that initiate that to at least
start the conversation they also
suggested that maybe it's time for us
all to take a look at police unions and
the power that police unions have when
you look at Officer Chauvin who had 18
complaints against him and only two
written reprimands and that he was still
on the force was troubling to all of
them
I also Anthony want to point out that we
had that conversation before there was
all of the talk about defunding the
police departments because I'm thinking
why didn't you ask about that well it
hadn't happened when we had that
conversation I would have been very
curious to get their thoughts on that
there's still a fascinating conversation
with those four Chiefs kale and I was I
was particularly struck by the one who
said that that what is it's things have
been tolerated in the police department
in part because they've been tolerated
in society so it you know with all this
focus on the police but it's it's a
larger issue I really it was a very
interesting conversation yeah and they
admit this feels different tomorrow
night I will anchor the CBS primetime
special we're calling it justice for all
it's at 10 o'clock 9:00 Central right
here on CBS it explores how the activism
that we're all seeing right now
following the death of George Floyd
could change racism within the ranks of
law enforcement in the country forever